wir schalten live nach lemberg genau
dort an diesen platz wo gestern die
kinderwagen waren dort steht unser
reporter philippe piatti
philipp ja das sind man kann die bilder
kaum in worte fassen haben wirklich
erschreckend
ja das war eine sehr schockierend eine
sehr besondere gedenkaktion die hier
gestern auf dem marktplatz auf dem ich
gerade stehe stattgefunden hat das sind
sehr viele menschen hier berührt und
mitgenommen man hat hier weinende frauen
gesehen tiere weinenden kinder gehalten
haben man hat viele kinder gesehen die
zu ihren eltern gegangen sind und
gefragt haben mama papa was ist das
eigentlich und dann mussten ihre eltern
den kindern ihren eigenen kindern
erklären was das bedeutet wenn kinder im
krieg sterben und auch in lemberg
bislang nicht erfasst wurde vom krieg
sowie andere städte es wurden hier sind
dennoch sehr viele flüchtlinge sehr
viele menschen die am eigenen leib
putins bomben erlebt haben die aus
kirchen und sind die aussage von sitz
und die gestern noch einmal daran
erinnert wurden was dieser krieg
wirklich bedeutet ja insbesondere r
gestern weil es dann wieder einen
angriff den zweiten gab schon innerhalb
weniger tage in der nähe des flughafens
von lemberg was bedeutet es dass es
jetzt innerhalb kurzer zeit jetzt zwei
angriffe gegeben hat
ja darüber rätseln hier alle militärs
denn das waren 2 präzisions schläge also
nicht das was man aus dem osten des
landes kennt wo das russische militär
städte das schon wahllos geschieht oder
sogar gezielt zivile einrichtungen
eingreift hier war das was anderes es
waren ganz präzise marschflugkörper die
einmal auf einer militärbasis
eingeschlagen sind und deutlich über 35
militärs getötet über 130 militärs
verwundet haben und gestern neben der
angriff auf eine wartungshalle direkt
auf dem flughafen gebäude das natürlich
sehr viele menschen wie nervös und die
militärs steigen sich auf den krieg
womöglich auch hierher kommt wäre der
russische blitzkrieg gelungen wäre
aufgefallen wäre das gut ich auch schon
hier jetzt konnte man ihn aushalten aber
die einschläge kommen näher
für den port of danke
rücken von lemberg weiter im westen der
ukraine allerdings in den süden und
schauen auf die hafenstadt odessa die
küstenmetropole am schwarzen meer auch
dort wächst die angst vor einem angriff
wir sehen hier auf der karte macht er
gerade haben wir sehr kurz gesehen dass
er immer mehr schiffe in stellung
gebracht werden möglicherweise landen
könnten und in der stadt hier sehen wie
es in der stadt
werden barrikaden aufgerichtet hier
haben wir noch mal die karte an dem man
sieht dass im landungsschiffe und
kriegsschiffe sich richtung odessa
bewegen eine million einwohner hat und
besser und in der stadt bereitet man
sich eben jetzt schon darauf vor das ist
möglicherweise zu straßen und häuser
kämpfen kommen könnte sollten die
russischen truppen dort landen wir gehen
zu sebastian prey er ist unser reporter
vor ort dort in odessa
sebastian hinter dir alles ruhig kein
mensch auf der straße du bist in einem
abgesperrten gebiet oder gibt es eine
ausgangssperre wie ist die situation
ja es ist ein ruhiger morgen hier in und
deshalb hat gestern abend ein bisschen
platt feuer gegeben weil offenbar eine
russische aufklärungsdrohne über der
stadt kreiste und ansonsten muss man
sagen die stimmung hier ist einfach
unheimlich du siehst ja selber sind kaum
menschen auf der straße kaum autos denn
putins flotte die hat sich vor der küste
in position gebracht wie lauert hinter
dem horizont man sieht sie vom strand
aus nicht aber die flotte ist da und die
menschen bereiten sich hier auf diesen
möglichen angriff vor es ist allerdings
sehr zermürbend denn niemand weiß wann
dieser angriff kommen wir das ist ein
bisschen ein psycho terror den putin ihr
verbreitet aber man ist vorbereitet auf
diesen angriff die stadt ist die reinste
festung überall gibt es stellungen
schützengräben sandsäcke
panzersperren man ist hier auf diesen
angriff vorbereitet man will die stadt
verteidigen und die russen auf jeden
fall zurückschlagen wenn es so weit
warum ist so deshalb für putin so
wichtig
sebastian kannst du mich noch nie konnte
ich es leider nicht verstehen wenn der
herr hören kannst warum ist deshalb für
putin so wichtig
deshalb hat einen großen
schwarzmeerhafen und vereinfacht gesagt
wer diesen hafen kontrolliert der
kontrolliert auch was für waren ins land
kommen sind also 60 prozent aller
wirtschaftsgüter die hier in die ukraine
verteilt werden aktuell natürlich viele
waffen viel munition und diesen h diese
diese nachschubroute die will putin
natürlich unterbrechen und bestenfalls
für seine eigenen truppen nutzen
wie würde sich so einen häuserkampf vor
dem sich die einwohner in odessa
offenbar jetzt schon rüsten eigentlich
ablaufen wie schwierig würde es für die
russen seien diese stadt überhaupt
einzunehmen
das ist auf jeden fall mit erheblicher
gegenwehr zu rechnen und ich denke mal
man würde wahrscheinlich so vorgehen wie
in allen anderen städten auch es würde
wahrscheinlich mit gezieltem
raketenbeschuss beginnen dann
artilleriefeuer man würde die stadt
erstmal weit schießen müssen denn jeder
weiß es ist sehr sehr schwierig an einem
strand an zu landen mit landung truppen
der strand ist hier verdient mit wenigen
maschinengewehr stellungen kann man den
den feind hier in schach gehalten es
wäre auf jeden fall ein blutbad wenn
putin sich wirklich dazu entschließen
sollte die stadt anzugreifen zumal es
dort katakomben gibt unter dieser stadt
leider habe ich die frage wieder nicht
hören können ja so was ja du hast
erzählt es gibt auch katakomben unter
der stadt was es noch mal besonders
schwierig macht
das richtig unter der stadt befindet
sich eines der größten unterirdischen
tunnel systeme der welt das sind
insgesamt
2500 kilometer katakomben die sich hier
unter odessa erstrecken sind bis zu 60
meter tief hier kann man natürlich
schutz suchen wenn es zu luftangriffen
kommt aber hier können sich auch
ukrainische soldaten unter der stadt
bewegen man kann hier unter feindlichen
linien auftauchen und aus dem hinterhalt
versuchen anzugreifen das ist auf jeden
fall eine große falle das weiß putin
auch und darauf ist er wahrscheinlich
vorbereitet aber hinterhalts angriffe
die sind auf jeden fall für seine
truppen extrem gefährlich